So without further a-dew let's get started
Lemme get a good look on this, lemme really get sniff on this one
*Snooter Snorting Intensifies*
*Light Flickering* UGH! Okay I'm out, I'm out OOOOH! AHG! NO! YGH! STOP!
WHY?! NO! WOAH WOAH WOAH!
WOAH! WoAH! WoAhOh!
*Dino Screams* WoAoh, DON'T DO THAT!
Alright, time to go forward i guess. AHEY! *Inaudible* Fucking steam©
WOAH! THAT WAS SPOTTING ME FOR-  AGHH! HAEJJ i'm fucked ;-; ah, hell hi :3 *MarkiScreams©* oh, ok, well
Fuck bye hello, bye, okay, let's guess that's how I scream then find all four rubber rings Mark *Logic = Condoms*
*Cat Mark* Weh? Sawwww *MarkiHorse noise* UGH! OH MEH GAWW ,OH MY GAW! I'M ESCAPING! I'M ESCAPIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIING!
*Meditating Mark* mmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmm *Interruption* AH! AH! AH!
Hey, I'm fine, My name is Mariplier okay alright
Hi, hello, my name is markiplier. I'm *Markisigh* I make videos on the internet oh
Oooh, huh, I got a nail. I don't know why I have a nail, but I got I got a nail
Oh, do I need a nail to be able to hang this thing up there?
*Spoop* AH! I'M TAKING A PICTURE OF YOU!
HOLY-SHIT *Hallelujah*
*Yoiee*
Hi
Yoiee? YOIEE?
Yoiee oiee me noiee wah yoi oii me noiee means! *Australian Triggered*
Why I don't like this hi. I don't want to play with your tiny man bon-bon all right
I guess this is normal ah
Yes!, I love this if I know my thing about cars *Dino Screaming: The Sequel*
HI! there's More than one of you!
That's a new predicament that I have to deal with and I can't sprint very far because I'm out of shape I eat too many
Donuts over at CAAAMP!. I think the trick is I just got to move quickly find. Whatever the hell I'm looking
*Spoop: The Sequel* WHY?!?!?
i got a rahk! HAAGH! OH! NO! OH GOD I DON'T WANNA UHG! please this is weird ;-;
Let's see Plun-ki-dohoho
Me am big smart in my brain hole, I'm braced. I'm so *Spoop: The Threequel*
Oh this looks whoa HEY HI!
Hi, how are you doing? Okay? Alright, well, I will pretend like that didn't happen. We know about your problem is it mannequins?!?!
Or is it all the poop in my pants
I think we got away from it
Oh my god, I know I see you movin' there
*Le' Clicke* AHHH! Bwaah fuck you ;-;
UHHH HEY! AHH THAT'S NOT GUUD
That's a pretty dramatic music you don't need to be playing that
What am I even looking for? I don't even know what it looks like. I don't even know what it smells like.
UH UH!
Hi, hi, sorry, I'm sorry it looked like I was that like crotch height
They're not my intention. Didn't mean to go face-first into your crotch panic panic
I'm panicking should I panic it's panicking what is suppose to do!?!? can't hide from me
I know what I'm about oh, okay i'm apparently i'm in a hole now i must be very small
Nobody make a joke about that *Insert Short Joke here*
I thought i was gonna di- AHH! OH GRAMMA, GRAMMA, GRAMMA NO!
No no I DON'T WANT THE COOKIES *Dino Scream: The FInale*
Fed to the rules and hit the ground runnin'
didnt make sense to live for fun *Demonitised*
Heyyy
I'm gonna throw you at a wall
I'm sorry.
Hello. How are you doing welcome to the *Spoop: The Finale?*
That chicken looks oddly
Promiscuous I don't wanna
I dun-wanna say nothin about that chicken but- uh- I
Can't lift that door with my butthole
There's no way AGHHH!
Well hey, oh hello oh excuse you
Please back up, Nope uh-uh
Nahhh nope no-uhn-uhn nooope~ *MarkiGiggle* I'm gonna go with a big ol'
Alright, see ya
Oh kayyyyyyyy!
Alright
That happened
Hey. i heard bangin' in here what's all the noise?  *Female Foxy appears* Yar yyyyyar yar yar
*Markigiggles: The Finale*
Oooh Ooogh, AHG! OHH ???
*DARKIPLIER?!?!*
Yoooo Well LET'S GAS IT UP!  I SAID LET'S GAS IT UP! I CAN NOT GAS IT UP! I AM TRYING! TO GAAS IT UP!
*SPOOP: THE FINALE* instant realization ... youve been fubernucked